accuse sexual predator and cult leader
Nathan chasing horse indicted by a Clark
County grand jury what this means is the
criminal case against the Dances with
Wolves actor moving forward and he's
officially charged only the eight news
now investigators were in court as this
major update was announced today Vanessa
Murphy has the latest
Ethan chasing horse appears to have some
devoted supporters but so do his alleged
victims it's really devastating to see
the amount of exploitation that he's
capable of doing to our culture and you
know how how much trauma he's really
caused a lot of people Lakota media
consultant Allison Renville is showing
support for the women and children
chasing horse is accused of victimizing
Renville is a tribal member from South
Dakota it's important for us to um bear
witness to these types of things because
we are the ones who are affected the
most moments after the alleged cult
leader appears in North Las Vegas
Justice Court Wednesday morning an
announcement in Clark County District
Court the criminal case against him is
moving forward charges defendant Nathan
chasing horse a grand jury indicting him
on 19 charges 10 counts of sexual
assault against a minor under the age of
16 and six counts of sexual assault
along with opening gross lewdness first
degree kidnapping of a minor and
trafficking in a controlled substance
according to this indictment obtained by
the 8 news now investigators the grand
jury heard testimony involving at least
two alleged victims the crimes are
alleged to have occurred between 2014
and 2020 and as for that drug charge
chasing horses accused of having a large
amount of psychedelic mushrooms
bail for chasing horse will remain at
three hundred thousand dollars he hasn't
posted Bond he remains locked up at the
Clark County Detention Center just
across the street and there's a petition
to keep him locked up that is demanding
that he be imprisoned for his crimes
against humanity as of Wednesday
afternoon more than 1100 signatures
unfortunately a lot of people who still
have that fear of retaliation and or
um spiritual abuse chasing horse also
faces federal charges along with
warrants in Montana and Canada as more
alleged victims are speaking up Vanessa
Murphy 8 news now as the eight news now
investigators have reported chasing
horse has previously been banned from
several Native American reservations
he's scheduled to appear here in court
on the 1st of March